my name is padre miguel roland i am the
parish priest lucky own administrator of the
catholic church of san cristobal
and since the first of november i am the
new pastor the new administrator
here of padre miguel parish you
have been here for a few years now in the
south of  Nevada I'm in Las Vegas' I've
been here San Cristóbal for about a year and a
half
Father Miguel, tell me a little bit about
how the pandemic has impacted your
community here because this pandemic is
worrisome and affects our
people in the parish a lot. We are about 90
percent.  One hundred Spanish-speaking people
is a very vulnerable population in
terms of the elderly and those
who have illnesses, so here
we are seeing about two or three funerals
a week and it is worrying for us.
We take precautions. We are taking
measures to care for ourselves and the
entire population, but  we are
offering the mass just call
for reservations
and follow the mask precautions
of l  spread your hands at a distance of one
meter etc. father inside the
church different measures are taken the
numbers of the cobi continue to grow
so what are they doing
here in their we have separate pews
and also marked so that families
are sitting
2 per pew perhaps  or one per pew on one
side and individuals and couples on the other
side and about 130-140
people gather every mass on Sunday
and there is plenty of room during the week but
we are taking the same precautions you
have to take your temperature before
entering all the necessary measures
because bishop jorge leal tomas and his
committee have told us what to do there are
many people who have died due to the
hobbit tell me a little bit about the masses
or how many people are more or less
how busy
the functional cement but
still the family is still  their sadness
has to put on their mask we take their
temperature and they meet to cry
together but they are very respectful and
we celebrate n  Our faith in the
resurrection is therefore a comfort, it is a
consolation to be able to offer the space,
it would still be sadder not to have the
opportunity or place to offer the
Holy Mass
with the body present or with the ashes.
Thank God we have that opportunity
to accompany people in  their mourning in their
sadness and their message for the
Catholic community here and now that the numbers
continue to grow that maybe we
don't know what tomorrow can bring you
that you have to tell them why they don't
get desperate that they follow the
instructions of the officials  to
take care of yourself and take precautionary measures and take
care of each other and
we don't know where the virus comes from but
it's not a matter of panic it's a matter of taking
care of yourself and following the recommendations
seriously it's not a
hoax it's something
of a public health crisis
then  we have to conform
not to be dissatisfied we have to
recover all together and
Catholics know how to come together in
communion and  matter of the holidays that
are to come well double triple take
the measures we are going to insist on the
rules even here in the masses